歡迎回來趙華
我想要問你啊
假如你現在呢
幹嘛回眸一笑啊
怎麼沒有回眸一笑啊
請說
假如你現在是壓滿的
百分之百持股
那你會一直一直很有信心嗎
然後市場跌了一萬點
你還會很有信心嗎
我應該就不會百分之百持股
所以可能這樣問不太準
因為我不會用到百分百
真的嗎
對
那你會用多少
算是你的上限
應該還是七成左右就上限了
就已经上线了
对对对
我也是
其实我都好习惯会留一些现金
持股比重
没有办法因为你拉得很高
所以今天我们的大来宾
他就会来跟大家详细的讲解
为什么
不管有没有遇到股灾
他有一个slogan
就叫做高持股
而且不要下车
我们先来欢迎他
就是我们的AI达人蔡明翰
赵华好 艾伦好 大家好
终于请到你了
因为说实话
以前我们赵华人说
都有请过明翰两三次
但是真的不好请
因为现在如果大家一打开
网路的这些财经平台
就会发现满满的都是明翰的脸
每个节目都有
对 明翰太受欢迎了
第一个当然是因为在AI上面的研究
从两三年开始
两三年前开始
就非常坚定的在这条路上
它完完全全是台美股的大主流
另外你有一个slogan
高持股有信心不下车
我现在看到很多喜欢你的人
都会复制这句话
貼在很多粉磚下面
為什麼會變成這樣的slogan
就像剛剛兩位講
說高持股到7成就有點壓力
其實我有點嚇一跳
你太膽小了嗎
我個人因為我長期而言
我真的大部分都維持在9成
甚至多一點點
然後就是9成上下跳動
我們先講清楚
我自己的定義持股
我都只有在講長線的部分
長線我才有所謂的持股比例
短線就是進進出出 來來回回
而且最主要問題是因為
我短線的比例本來就不高
無論如何大概也不會高過一成
所以我不太在意短線那邊
我永遠講持股
我只在意我的長線
我的長線確實
應該說自從有AI以來
等於二三年以來
我持股很少低於九成
等於說應該說我的動作
只會加不太會減
因為我覺得一直覺得趨勢還在
那所以我常常講嚇不掉我
就是那些川普啊
或是什麼因子
我覺得其實對產業來講
其實影響都非常有限
所以我一直覺得
維持高持股是一個很重要的關鍵
好 明翰市CFA的Level 3
其實有過一段非常非常精彩的
求學歷程到考上這麼難考的證照
到第三級
但是今天可能沒有辦法
跟大家詳細的說明
如果大家有興趣的話
可以去聽我的Podcast
有聊過這一段
從幾乎是不良少年吧
對不對 飆車族 打架
然後到可以去念到
九星山大學的財務分析碩士
然後還有這個特許分析師執照
反正簡單的結論就是
我以前在退伍以前
我對讀書沒什麼太大的興趣
那到準備退伍找不到工作
才發現我到底想要做什麼
可是我其實我也沒有什麼概念
我老實說我對股票
也沒有什麼太大的興趣
我那時候只愛玩而已
只會一直以來
我父親上班就是穿西裝
然後每天朝九晚
我覺得看起來很羨慕 很帥
所以我就想要找一個
穿西裝上班的工作爐子而已
那當時就覺得
看起來好像看股票還不錯
然後就往這條路走
但是很明顯切點
就從我退伍之後
就非常認真
每天等於說
讀書的時間真的拉得很長
然後等到進入研究
最後到現在的工作
其實老實講
工作時長一直以來都蠻長的
最後我常常講這個
你沒有點興趣
支撐不了這種所謂的長久的工作
這是我自己概念
所以當然後續來講
就是真的是自己的興趣
或者說我離開國泰
現在真的是等於說
自己想做什麼就做什麼
自己又選擇
那未來來講
我覺得最起碼
我現在還是做得很開心
我對研究來講
是我的興趣所在
好 離開國泰以後
真的是所有的節目
都瘋狂的在找民憾
剛剛講說錄完我們的
他晚上還要去弄自己的東西
明天還有好幾場的露營
但是現階段
除了剛剛講到的高持股
有信心不下車
新法策略
以及有一些經驗分享是
我常常覺得你找到的資料
好強喔
到底是怎麼找到的
除了我們每個月可以看到
什麼營修數據
總經數據之外
這邊可不可以教教大家
你是怎麼樣做決策的
還有為什麼可以
分長線短線投資
然後長線的都不下車
好 我常常講
就是你要有信心
最重要重點
你要先把長短線去做區分
那尤其是無論是個股
或自己的部位
其實長短線真的不要混在一起
我應該這樣講
這個是我以前一直以來
也常常犯的錯誤
尤其是我應該這樣講
接近20年的這個職業
包含我自己的投資
其實前半段
我也是跟一般投資人
沒什麼太大的差別
就是我也不會長短線區分
我也不知道什麼
反正現在市場什麼夯就買什麼
但後來慢慢的經過
一點點的長線投資之後發現
長線投資老實說
我個人覺得又輕鬆
而且重點輕鬆之外
重點是獲利其實明顯的比短線好很多
這是我自己的問題
那我覺得投資人最主要的問題
就是他在長短線部分之外
還有一個很重要的關鍵點
一直每天要想盡辦法把報酬率拉高
我常常講這也是我以前的關鍵
我們法人每天都有不同的訊息
然後都會覺得我自己的訊息
只有我知道我自己特別厲害
然後人家跟我講我就一定要去買
然後每個都買
然後呢不是說
不是說這些訊息不準或怎樣
但是我只能說
訊息不可能百分之百一定正確
你可能五個裡面你中三個
然後兩個失敗了
那加總是往上走的沒錯
但最重要的關鍵點
你經不起震盪
你只要中間無論川普說什麼
連準會說什麼你就很緊張
然後你就趕快必須要去做檢碼
然後就是永遠在檢碼加碼當中
那我常常講就是說
你今天賺的錢其實投入了資金加上報酬率
每天想辦法要去拉高報酬率
我覺得應該我後來給自己的目標都是以
大盤為原則
我的目標只要打贏大盤就好
我不會想到說現在哪裡最強
我就一定要往哪裡衝
那這是我自己的觀念
那重點我剛剛提到
高持股是很重要的
我自己覺得這個工作
因為可以看到
從這個2023年
就我剛剛講的
就是從AI真的比較定義開始
到現在為止的收盤價
你可以看到加權指數
這三年來漲了兩倍以上
那這個如果0050已經漲了三倍
台積電漲了四倍
這什麼概念就是你三年前丟100萬進去其實你買台積電現在已經賺了超過400萬那我常常講的而EWO以前確實進進出出短線有信息
確實很快可以從100萬
就拉高到300 400萬
其實不難
但是中間只要遇到一狀況
瞬間可能又回到剩100萬
然後你可能這三年
又有點白做工的感覺
那你長線只要跟著指數
缺點是什麼
就是你的這個獲利的這個頻率
或者說你的速度
可能沒有感覺市場這麼夯
你有時候可能比市場好一點
有時候比市場慢一點
但長期而言重點是我後來
長這樣的一個角度而已
如果最近的績效比大盤落後
其實我一點都不會緊張
我不會覺得為什麼最近大家都
買什麼賺大錢只有我沒有
所以我個人覺得其實對我來講
並不會有那麼大的壓力
只要時間拉長 趨勢正確
而且我要講一個概念
就是這是我自己後來感受到的經驗
就是我自己的一個心態的轉變
我剛剛講一開始我進入法輪圈
也是很重視這個股價的一個部分
每天的漲跌
如自己手上的持股
到底每天收盤
可能漲了3塊錢
或漲了1.25%
那個小數點都會非常精確
因為每天非常重視股價
但是對於基本面而言
會講到那這檔個股
營收這個月到底往上還往下
其實我忘了
好像我好像上個月沒看
就是基本面不見那麼重視
但每天的股價都很重視
為什麼 因為每天就在講哪裡強
你可能常常持股一個禮拜就換
所以這個營收
可能一個月再公佈一次
可是你持股只有一週
所以老實講
你對基本面根本就不在意
但缺點來講
你就很耐不住正
那不是只有你這檔個股的問題而已
包含大盤出了什麼狀況
美國說了什麼事情
只要指數一拉回
你就會擔心
哎呀我買這檔個股
可能撐不住
然後就很容易震盪
所以最後慢慢的
就剛剛提到
如果拉長線重視基本面之後
其實最明顯就兩個優勢
第一個就是不怕震盪
你不管發生什麼事情
我都有我的長遠
原本的想法
我常講AI的概念也很簡單
這個一個漏斗下來
其實最重要的
前端就是因為美國四大雲端
業者不斷砸錢
所以自然來要為我們加買硬體
這概念不變
所以無論發生什麼事情
我現在投資就是半年後
所謂的資本支出會不會再增加
那這些論點不會因為美意開戰
不會因為油價轉強
不會因為川普說了什麼事情
就導致我原本的初衷
會有所改變
所以中間震盪我並不會害怕
股價波動不代表價值的改變
但很多人把兩件事綁在一起
另外一個更重要
就是長線才有辦法累積財富
這也是我之前
就是我如果剛剛提到
這20年來前10年跟後10年
完全不同的世界
因為我前面10年永遠就是
哪裡強往哪裡跑
那特色就是
沒有錯我可以50萬很快
就變500萬
可是只要遇到一個狀況
一下馬上又會回徒到
接近原點的位置
那重點就是你必須
你的錢要必須待得住在裡面
我覺得這是很重要的工作
當然講到這個時候
投資人常常講
那個是因為你已經有資金
我沒有資金
你兩三年前就投了
現在才要進場
對 這兩個問題
第一個我常常講資金
我簡單而言
以前我剛入行的時候
也是三五十萬開始
那這是一個重點
第二個我當時也那麼覺得
說會覺得
我剛剛提到我自己從小部位
一直到法人操作
就是幾億資金在操作
我後來發現
所有的沒有資金大小的問題
操作都是同個邏輯
我們永遠比的都是一個比重
就是我們常常在投資也就問
你現在持股比例是多少
不會有人問你最近買多少
因為每個人的部位不一樣
那你說即使國安基金
這麼大的部位
他永遠也是按照的比例下去投資
所以其實投資邏輯
跟你的本金有多少
其實並沒有太直接的關係
第二個就是剛剛趙華提到
我們很多人講
那個是因為你兩年前進場的概念
那我們就要繼續往下看
就是講到
到底基本面要怎麼去觀察
而且後續的變化要怎麼去瞭解
那我常講
基本面的一個部分
每月每季必做的功課
一定要做到
就是所謂的月營收跟季保
這兩個一定要去了解
那即使我常講
就算你操作的時間軸比較短
你的個股可能是一兩週的持股
可是他現在的營收跟獲利
到底怎樣
你都有點不太清楚
你就很容易被所謂的震出去
所以提到兩個對比而言
我會覺得營收又比季報
相對來講更重要
因為畢竟啊
雖然說就股東的一個角度
會覺得所謂的季報才有獲利
獲利對股東而言
就是我們投資人而言
才是最重要的工作沒錯
但是有個缺點
因為季報就是每一季三個月才有
那營收的部分其實有點領先的作用
所以我個人而言
其實我比較重視是每月的這個營收的一個角度
乖乖的去做這些功課
我常講你不用知道整體的狀況
你不用知道其他人
但你手中持股十檔
你對這十檔現在績效表現如何
你最起碼總該知道
甚至我常講的
買股票可能大家沒概念
你把它想成說你家隔壁的便當店
然後可能鄰居好朋友
他要希望你幫他
他可能資金不夠叫你參股
你說我拿10萬塊
投資在你這家便當店
他每天經過他業績好不好
你總會看一下 好奇一下
你為什麼會投資一家公司
對於他現在營運好壞
你一點概念都沒有
所以我覺得這是很重要的關鍵點
所以一定要了解他目前
到底是慢慢越來越好
還是最近已經開始反轉向下
你才不會抱著這些股票
持續往下一直找不到低點
好 因為你有一些資料很厲害
所以很好奇
你現在到底用到的付費軟體
或者是資料庫
你會比較看哪一些
另外你其實很早
在AI只是會幫忙生成圖的時候
你上達人秀
就已經開始用AI做圖了
那現在AI可以做的事情
是不是更多了
應該這樣講
當然我常講
我只要在研究的時間點
我只要電腦打開
永遠都開著AI
然後所有東西一定都靠AI輔助
那當然我們有比較特別
就是我們有這個
所謂的資料的軟體
這個資料軟體來講
我覺得老實說
我覺得對一般投資人
可能比較不適用
而且我這樣講也不用擔心
我個人覺得雖然不適用
但是也有沒有那個軟體
其實關鍵點並不大
其實真的我還是回過頭來提到
AI真的可以幫忙
大家非常非常多的事情
其實最主要關鍵點
你要靠著AI要做兩件事第一個是你自己的訓練你常常講你要先 你的關鍵點在哪裡是你到底應該要問什麼你要先一個概念
比如說今天
比如說今天大力光很強
我可以買大力光嗎
這個論點通常回答的結果都很爛
你要抽絲剝繭
一層一層的下去問
你一開始可能也許先問說
我就我的角度
一開始就先問
今天大力光為什麼這麼強
對不對 他總會有告訴你幾個原因
然後他會告訴你說
我覺得這個時候
可能都還沒有太大的幫助
我只講幾個問題舉個例子
比如說他會告訴你
最近大家都認為
他跨入CPO了
那這個時候其實
對投資都還沒有幫助
要繼續問下去
那你說那進入CPO了
他到底在CPO的哪一個段落
那他會告訴你
他中間做了一個光學元件
然後呢最重要重點
我還是要回歸數字
對不對 那你可以問他說
就現在的角度
他的營收開始貢獻了嗎
他就可以幫你統計
他就說
結論就是目前還沒有貢獻
那你就可以繼續問下去
就法人推估跟公司法縮會的說法
他應該會在哪個時間點
營收會慢慢出現
他就會給你一個時間點
這時候我覺得對投資
你還要繼續問下去
你要問他說
那你剛剛這個論點
尤其可能是公司說
有可能是法人說
你要告訴我
你覺得這個
陳真的機會有多少
他如果最後
miss的機會有多少
你的論點是在哪裡
一直一直追問下去
到最後你就知道
這檔股票
你應該給他的是一個短線
大家跟題材的投資
還是長線
他真的即將獲利值
是我不知道
所以老實講
就是真的可以多找AI幫忙
他無論是在
趨勢面或者是數字面
其實都可以帶給你非常大的幫助
有些我常常遇到投資人
我就講這個論點
他就說
可是他真的不知道
到底怎麼用AI
我只能講一個角度
你面對我的時候
你就一直舉手
所以我可不可以問問題
問問題
問這個怎樣
我說你記得
你所有舉手問的問題
你打開AI跟他對話
你把他當他就是我
你怎麼問我
你就怎麼問他
他自然就會該有回答
這是第一點
第二點要記得
AI現在它還是會有
具有那幻想的問題
它常常會回答一些
莫名其妙不太正確的答案
所以你必須要去了解到
這個趨勢之外
你必須要有點防錯
或者是我常常講的
如果一般投資人
可能沒辦法去辨別
有一個比較好的方式
你把它最起碼去開個
兩到三個這個不同的AI
然後問一樣的問題
甚至抓出來的數字
去對比一下
你就知道到底正不正確
使用一個AI
好像也沒有這麼的容易
但是也是一個自我訓練的過程
好 剛剛有提到
高持股有信心
大概已經理解的一個原理
但是說實話
每次遇到修正
你都會第一個回答
沒什麼問題
但是沒有什麼問題
要有一個很強的
例如說數據
基本面
未來的願景做支撐
對 我這樣講
先給大家概念
這我自己的論點
我是沒看過市場怎麼解讀
但我以前一直回溯
我的經驗就是
股價會提前市場
最長就是兩季
然後所以呢
代表就以現在八月為例
所以你很多的個股在講
今年會有多厲害
很有可能股價都已經反映
然後這時候投資人
也很擔心說
所以最近在回檔
會不會已經
反應完了
Party已經全部都結束
我說你如果到07年
還在往上
就不可能現在
已經全部反映完
因為就是半年的時間
那我們在講
你常會覺得說位階很高
就是因為你對基本面
可能不是很了解
左邊的是營收
右邊的是獲利
只要概念就是
到7月的整體上市過於營收
年增率47
累積前7個月年增34
第二季剛剛公佈的這個財報
年增140%
然後我常常講
這些當然有激期的問題
但是現在在創立時薪高都是真的
這是扎扎實實的數字
那常常會講
這都是已經發生的概念
那我們常常講到底貴不貴
這個是加權指數的本益比走勢
你會發現
沒錯前一段時間在瘋狂的時候
確實有創高
但幅度也不是很大
最近壓回又在原本的整理區間了
那重點呢
這個台股的部分
還是以台積電在帶領
它的獲利EPS
從去年底到現在
這一段增長
就是預估今年的EPS增長
就超過四成以上
所以這都在反映今年的股價
為什麼能夠這麼強
更重要就是
台積電我們就不是只有看本益比
還要再除上它的這個成長率
就是PEG
那可以看到股價藍色的線不斷走高
但是它的PEG卻持續的走低
就是它股價的漲幅
一直都追不上它的成長力道
所以台積電來講
我常講台積電目前還是
相對比較安全的一檔個股
它安全就代表著指數泡沫的機率
老實講並不高
那我們前段
就是給大家一些
目前看得到的數字
我們再來講一些
剛剛提到的
到底未來
會不會這些都已經反應了
我們就來看未來
前段就提到
台股有一個最大的利益
就是所謂雲端的資本支出
從26 27 28年
每年持續增長
那這些應該這樣講
26增長9成
明年後年是用拆的
所以有些人會懷疑
這個拆的數字
那我只要告訴大家
這是雲端巨頭的
所謂的積壓訂單
他們會投入
就是因為他們拿到的訂單
在持續噴出
所以他為了要應付這些訂單
必須得投入
所以這個是
所謂常常講訂單是這些
所謂投入的領先指標
所以如果一層一層來看
我常講為什麼我有信心
我看到半年後
我半年後看了什麼
是資本支出
資本支出的前端是什麼
就是這些訂單
所以我個人的論點
你只要這些訂單
沒有出現反轉
代表支出不會反轉
代表我們台灣的硬體廠
還在持續走高
所以這個是一層一層的
這個概念
回過頭來那是從海外角度
我們回到台股的部分
出口
出口就是扎實的現在的狀況
那也是不斷的在維持高檔創高
那我常常講
這個也是已經發生
我們就看一下外銷訂單
那一樣就是靠電子產品
跟直通訊的部分持續
創歷史新高
那這些都一樣
我剛剛提到
如果就這樣層層的堆疊
等於是台股
我們看企業營收
企業營收前面看資本支出
資本支出前看訂單
所以只要回過頭來
無論是剛剛提到
雲端的這些訂單
或者是外銷出口的訂單
只要沒有反轉之前
其他你包含川普啦
包含聯準會啦
我覺得那些老江
我覺得都不是那麼重要
好 當然反轉這件事情
你會觀察多久
例如說剛好有一個月
可能外銷訂單的年增率
有點不如預期下來了
或是出口的狀況有一點點低迷了我們要怎麼綜合判斷所謂真正的反轉呢應該這樣講從數字面還有包含產業面也會有一定的相關
因為有一個可能性
就像現在的這個
輝達的這個所謂硬體正在轉換
所以呢
當然有可能會在這個轉換期
導致營收出口的數字稍微掉
所以這塊就要靠著自己的
對產業的了解
因為還沒出現
我就有可能知道有可能會掉
所以代表掉的時候
相對來講 我不會那麼恐慌
但是如果今天反向而言
如果現在不是有任何的一個轉變期
應該是一個噴出期
那突然反而出現轉變
那我可能就要花比較多的時間
最後如果找不出原因
我可能就會選擇稍微撤退
以防萬一有反轉的風險
好 因為都是從基本面出發
市場的資金面
就像你剛剛講的
升不升息 降不降息
你一點都不參考嗎
因為像最近我們有討論到的
可能M1B跟M2的動能
也在趨緩 錢再變少
這個您會考慮嗎
不會考慮
很簡單的道理
我只給一個中心思想
從2020年到現在
指數漲了四倍
外資賣超了四兆
就是指數會漲
完全是獲利導致
是因為台積電的獲利漲了八倍
所以導致指數漲了四倍
跟誰買誰賣
現在大家會不會害怕
沒有關係
你會動搖不了他
對 我還用到您了
那這邊的話可能有點問了廢話
但是就是需要民漢幫我們
再度的加強信心
看好的產業跟原因
因為等一下會有檔股票
是今天跌停版的
我想這就是考驗大家信心的時候
但我們先從AI關鍵產品來講
好 我們先講
這個是台達電
因為它是電子
應該說在AI伺服器的電源供應器
它最主要關鍵點
是市占率超過五成以上
所以它就是產業的龍頭
左邊的圖是告訴大家
電源供應器
它的這個年增長其實超過100%
會延續在這幾年
綠色點是在台達電
可以看到這邊就是所謂的
它的市占率
從今年開始會超過五成
而且會持續往上
代表著它就是市場龍頭
它說了算
所以常常這樣講
只要它搭上龍頭
代表著
AI沒有反轉之前
它都還會持續走高
這個概念理論上不會有太大變化
所以從三年的營收看到
這就是標準的AI族群
就是每年穩穩的往上
而且每一條線不交跌
這就是我
對這種營收的個股
我都會特別喜愛
那當然股價從2500跌到1400
但是我覺得對我而言
我就想不要說1400
你跌到400我還是照買
只要這個趨勢不變
我就敢買
這每個人的概念不變
因為我理論上
我就是一個所謂的
基本面為中心思想
它的營收可以創高
它的獲利可以創高
它在AI趨勢上
它又是龍頭
我就不相信它可以跌到哪裡去
對我而言越跌我越興奮
因為下面我敢買
所以每個人的信念不同
當然很多人看到
現在的這個角度
就沿路破線
而且所有均線糾結反轉向下
看起來是最慘的時間點
可是我敢買
因為我覺得對基本面
我有比較堅強的信心
另外剛剛提到
今天繼續吃一根跌停的旺系
那一樣概念其實
我常講現在是它的股價很慘
也不會太意外
那我們講長線就好
因為探針卡的部分
它有一個比較明顯的利基
也是試占率過五成
所以也是具有龍頭的地位
那外資 這是外資的預估
就是營收毛利率
我們看的比較長線
到28年之前
都不會有太大的改變
這是長線
其實它比較重要的關鍵點
就是看到它的營收
因為它的這個所謂的
當時5月的營收大幅的飆升
是 這邊飆
對 然後呢 就開始
對 那你會發現喔
你可以看到去年的綠色線也差不多
在那個高點之後
因為出貨的量突然拉高之後
這邊也一樣耶
對對對
所以本來就會有一點震盪拉回
然後導致應該說市場看到
之前第二季太好
所以本來認為第三季會再往上噴出
公司的說法很簡單
就是我的產能就只有這麼多
那現在我能產的已經全部都賣掉了
所以未來呢
營收再增加
就只能調漲價格跟增加產能
然後第四季才會調漲這個報價
明年才會再增加產能
所以這需要一點時間
所以目前來講股價確實就是很弱勢
那應該說目前來講跌升會反彈
但是這種股票它就是要等到第四季
所以切記就是反彈的時候
絕對不是你的買點
一樣的問題
跌停的時候進去多少買一點
報到年底其實是有空間的
因為你每次上來
如果你追在這裡
壓到這裡的時候你會受不了
所以上去不用買
因為這幾個月業績就是不好
但是要記得這是短線的
它是因為拉貨時間跑
卡在第二季
導致現在動能降低
但是重點在需求的部分
完全沒有任何改變
好 但我們要如何知道
像台達電
我們也是從講的
四五百 三四百就開始看
怎樣叫做本益比合理
對不對
然後例如旺汐也是
不到一千
看到它漲到七千多又修正
可是我怎麼知道
它是不是已經把未來的動能漲完
這件事到底要怎麼評估
那個平衡點
好這個趙華
如果有這個問題
我說如果
問AI是不是
不是不是
我覺得這個問題
要符合這個條件
只有台積電可以
就是他維持高成長
那本益比一直在合理範圍之內
那這個你就只能買台積電
如果這些AI強勢族群
我不是講股價
我是說基本面強勢的AI股
其實現在的普遍的問題
已經沒辦法去評價
他該有的價格
本益比都已經創歷史新高
那應該說
我們就以台達電為例
以前他本益比就是
一二十倍
那前一段時間
飆到50幾倍 接近60倍
那回過頭來
如果你每一次呢
就覺得不合理就出場
其實不到30倍你就出場
等於說不到一千塊
你就再也不可能
再買到這檔股票
那常常的問題就是說
是不是已經提前反應
我剛剛講有可能
所以你要有個心理準備
萬一你買在最高點
你最長最長
我剛剛提到股價就是
最多反應半年
所以最多就是等到半年後
發現它的獲利還在創高
自然又會再創高
所以中間你要有心理準備
最慘就是可能會被套一到兩劑
那中間你就必須要
有耐心的持續買進
但買進的過程當中
你要持續盯著他的營收跟獲利
不能反轉喔
不能反轉向下
你就閉著眼睛買
這也是錯誤的
你第一 長線趨勢對
第二 下來敢買
第三 你要做好功課
營收獲利還在成長
這段時間只要耐得住這關痛苦期
未來等到它創高之後
你永遠都是買在最低點
好今天謝謝明翰
我覺得觀眾應該是很羨慕我們
明翰叫我們問AI
我都直接問AI達人
而且跟他擄他都不厭其煩
動搖不了他
其實就跟你看的縣徒一樣
我問他縣徒的時候也動搖不了他
他的基準就是看縣徒為主
所以今天如果縣不好的時候
也動搖不了你
就是不好
兩位的信念都是無可動的